la mattina del 14 novembre 2014
appena alzato faccio colazione come
tutte le mattine accendo il computer
controllo le mail appena arrivate mi
accingo a mettermi al lavoro certo
momento fibra il cellulare il mio
smartphone una notifica da parte di
facebook che mi ricorda di fare gli
auguri di compleanno al mio amico
alessandro contribuisce a rendere unica
la sua giornata alla classica frase che
viene indicata
peccato che alessandro era morto tre
mesi prima
questa cosa è scioccante 1 sta pensando
le proprie attività quotidiane sta
pensando appunto al lavoro che deve
svolgere il proprio smartphone
a un certo momento gli ricorda che di
fare gli auguri di compleanno un amico
che è morto la prima reazione che mi
viene da fare è quella di andare sulla
pagina facebook di alessandro e quindi
rileggere gli ultimi post che ha
pubblicato riguardo alle sue fotografie
mi viene da entrare su messenger su
whatsapp e rileggere delle conversazioni
private che abbiamo avuto
ribadisco la cosa è molto scioccante ha
un impatto emotivo molto forte però
superato questo impatto emotivo
mi rendo consapevole di quanto il social
network ci pongano dinanzi agli occhi la
morte i morti e qui faccio un passo
indietro io sono un tana tolo go vale a
dio e da quasi dieci anni mi occupo dal
punto di vista filosofico del tema della
morte
svolgo attività di def education negli
ospedali con associazioni private con
fondazioni cioè cerco di riportare il
discorso della morte all'interno della
nostra società
questo perché perché ormai noi siamo
abituati a rimuovere la morte dai luoghi
all'interno di cui
noi viviamo quotidianamente parlare di
morte inopportuno è un argomento tabù e
scabroso scatta subito la scaramanzia
questo è mai un fenomeno che si è
sviluppato da diversi decenni con tutta
una serie di conseguenze molto
problematiche nel secolo scorso un
sociologo jeff aveva parlato di
pornografia della morte perché sosteneva
che la morte ha sostituito il sesso come
il grande tabù della nostra epoca
per dare l'idea di questo di quanto sia
difficile parlare di morte
riporto un indagine di mercato
decisamente curiosa fatta in italia
parrebbe che le case che sono collocate
vicino ai cimiteri delle nostre città
abbiano un costo inferiore del 50 per
cento rispetto a casa della stessa
grandezza site in altri luoghi delle
nostre città questo anche quando i
cimiteri sono in zone molto centrali
come il verano a roma
o come il monumentale a torino questo
cosa significa che in linea generale le
persone non hanno voglia di vivere
accanto ai cimiteri non hanno voglia
quando tornano dal lavoro di guardare il
luogo dei morti che ovviamente gli
ricorda che siamo tutti mortali che
prima o poi toccherà anche a noi le
persone non hanno voglia e la domenica
mattina di affacciarsi alla finestra
invece di vedere un campo di fiori
vedere il luogo dove ci sono le tombe
delle persone morte
quindi le persone non hanno voglia di
stare accanto i cimiteri
peccato che nel momento in cui prendono
loro smartphone e si collegano a
facebook si ritrovano dinanzi ai loro
occhi il più grande cimitero che vi sia
attualmente al mondo si calcolano
all'incirca 50 milioni di uteri profili
di utenti deceduti parlerebbe a livello
statistico che ogni giorno muoiono circa
33 mila utenti di facebook siamo
arrivati all
tanto che secondo una serie di indagini
statistiche a fine secolo
se facebook ci sarà ancora i profili
degli utenti deceduti saranno in numero
superiore rispetto a quelli dei vivi
questo perché meno persone si
iscriveranno probabilmente su facebook e
perché generalmente chi vive non pensa
quale sarà il futuro dei propri del
proprio profilo quindi un luogo un
social network che è nato per creare
relazioni per flirtare per condividere
fake news per litigare col proprio
vicino di casa diverrà molto presto una
grandissima enciclopedia dei morti un
luogo dove i morti saranno in numero
superiore rispetto ai vivi
ovviamente questo tipo di situazione già
oggi crea tutta una serie di conseguenze
piuttosto interessanti anche piuttosto
peculiare soprattutto in relazione
all'elaborazione del lutto in relazione
al nostro modo di vivere la mortalità in
relazione anche al nostro modo di
pensare l'immortalità
mi soffermo inizialmente sulla questione
del lutto
tutti noi sappiamo come funziona quando
ci muove una persona cara e quando
soffriamo per un grave lutto dopo un
primo momento in quelle persone ci sono
vicine c'è il cordoglio a un certo
momento ci ritroviamo una specie di
bolla autistica che ci sta attorno non
sa cosa dire ha imbarazzato ci vede
sofferenti
il datore di lavoro poi dice va bene ok
puoi andare al cimitero al funerale però
cerca di riprendersi in fretta perché
bisogna produrre e quindi le persone si
ritrovano a dover ad avere questo dolore
fortissimo dentro di sé e non avere un
sostegno da parte degli altri
il social network tendono sempre più a
sopperire a questa mancanza
c'è sempre più il tentativo di fare
gruppo di elaborare collettivamente
insieme
lutto all'interno dei social interno
soprattutto di facebook allora si
cominciano a pubblicare status post sul
profilo del morto parlandogli
direttamente come se lui potesse leggere
si commenta tra le persone conosciute
anche con le persone sconosciute su
questo lutto lo schermo che in fondo ci
toglie la presenza fisica in qualche
modo facilità
l'esposizione dei propri sentimenti ci
sono delle pagine apposite dedicate
fondamentalmente a chi sta soffrendo un
lodo una di quelle che a me ha colpito
di più è una pagina dedicata ai genitori
che hanno perso dei figli ventenni in un
incidente stradale
quindi una pagina specie che riguarda un
lutto molto specifico e che quindi
permette a persone che hanno condiviso
la stessa sofferenza anche se non si
conoscono di fare gruppo riusciva in
qualche modo tramite le esperienze
comuni a darsi sostegno uno con l'altro
credo sono anzi convinto che a molti in
sala sarà capitato di mandare su
whatsapp un messaggio o morto capita
frequentemente quello di scrivere un
messaggio su whatsapp alle persone che
non ci sono più ma non perché ci si
aspetta che ci sia la doppia spunta blu
e quindi ci si aspetta che ci sia quindi
una visualizzazione è un collegamento
romantico un collegamento simbolico in
cui colui che ancora in vita
sta bene perché in qualche modo sente di
dover riusciti continuare a comunicare
con colui che non c'è più un po come
quelle persone che vanno sulla tomba nei
cimiteri e parlano con i morti
raccontando quello che hanno fatto nel
corso della loro vita
ci sono anche dei casi molto particolari
e che creano tutta una serie di problemi
uno di questi casi che a me ha colpito
di più che vi racconto questo in
provincia di cuneo muovono un ragazzo
ventenne in montagna la madre scopre le
sue credenziali di accesso
entra e comincia a pubblicare dei post
in prima persona come se fosse il
ragazzo scrivere ma cose del tipo molto
banali cose del tipo per dio e nel
giorno di natale
lei scrive so che state soffrendo senza
di me ma io sono col pensiero con voi e
vi guardo dall'alto cose di questo di
questo tipo cose che per lei
probabilmente fanno bene per superare
una tragedia così gigantesca è molto
problematica per una situazione di
questo tipo
innanzitutto perché altre persone che
hanno patito lo stesso lutto possono
trovare scioccante vedere uno status
scritto dal mo come se fosse il morto
presente inoltre noi da quando
utilizziamo i social network sviluppiamo
una sorta di identità digitale
un'identità digitale la cui fisicità la
cui corporeità e il messaggio che
veicoliamo nei confronti altrui
quindi in altre parole la madre con
questo gesto si appropria della
corporeità digitale del figlio veste i
panni del figlio che non c'è più e non è
detto che quel figlio sarebbe stato
contento nel pensare che sua madre una
volta morto fa ebbe scritto come se lui
in prima persona come se fosse lui ma
questo aspetto questo questa particolare
situazione ci porta a fare un
ragionamento ulteriore quando la nostra
morte biologica non coincide mai con la
nostra morte digitale
mi spiego quando noi ma è una cosa
banale quando noi muoviamo la nostra
vita termina ma tutto ciò che noi
abbiamo condiviso online sui social
network nel web nei blog continua a
vagare come se nulla fosse successo
c'è una specie di non coincidenza tra
questi due tipi tra le due vite la vita
biologica e la vita digitale
questo ha fatto riflettere diversi
scienziati diversi scienze
beati i quali hanno pensato che questa
non coincidenza tra le due morti e
quindi le due vite possa essere
utilizzata per regalarci una sorta di
immortalità digitale in che modo
anche qui torna utile la narrazione
tutti conoscerete probabilmente black
mirror e la famosa vicenda la famosa
puntata torna da me in cui due a una
coppia di ragazzi lui muove e la ragazza
tramite un software continua a chattare
con lo spettro digitale del morto
addirittura comincia a parlare con la
voce senza bocca del morto che una
rielaborazione delle registrazioni di
colui che non c'è più questa cosa è
diventata reale gli esperimenti nei
confronti di questo tipo sono sempre
maggiori
faccio degli esempi faccio soprattutto
un esempio non quello più noto di solito
viene citato un esempio russo ma qui
viene porto un altro che mi ha molto
colpito un giornalista scientifico james
laos scopre che suo padre ottantenne ha
una malattia tumorale che lo porterà
molto probabilmente a morire
dato che questo padre era un uomo che
faceva teatro era un uomo molto attivo
che ha avuto una vita molto ricca decide
di sfruttare la sua professione e di
scrivere una biografia in ricordo del
padre
dunque durante la malattia registra le
conversazioni con suo padre si fa
raccontare tutta la sua vita
ma la cosa gli sfugge di mano si ritrova
un quantitativo di file enorme per cui
avrebbe dovuto scrivere un libro di
centinaia e centinaia di pagine che cosa
pensa dice invece di scrivere un libro
perché non rielaborare tutto questo
materiale e renderlo attivo perché non
far sopravvivere le parole stesse di mio
padre
oltre alla sua morte e allora si crea
una quello che lui definisce un dead bot
un chatbot che rielabora
fondamentalmente i contenuti delle
conversazioni
stazioni col pad e che permette al
figlio una volta che suo padre morto di
continuare a chattare con lui in una
delle conversazioni riportate dai
giornali su questo fatto che ovviamente
ha colpito molte persone legge c'è uno
scambio che a me ha molto colpito molto
fatto sorridere a un certo momento il
figlio chiede al padre ma nessuno dove
sei
il padre risponde ma che domanda stupida
sono un luogo dove c'è una connessione
wifi se non potrò assolutamente
rispondere
stiamo in altre parole volenti o nolenti
trasportando l'aldilà il paradiso quello
qualunque cosa qualunque forma in cui
noi diamo all'aldilà all'interno degli
dei nostri smartphone
stiamo portando appunto la al di là
dentro i nostri smartphone smartphone
dentro i nostri computer addirittura in
america si sta sempre più pensando di
creare gli ologrammi delle persone vale
a dire di utilizzare tutto il materiale
che noi condividiamo online per ricreare
delle riproduzioni dei morti lo stanno
già facendo con i personaggi famosi
mentre noi siamo qui a discutere da
qualche parte del mondo c'è il
l'ologramma di ronnie james dio il
famoso cantante dei black sabbath che
sta facendo un concerto con dei
musicisti in carne e ossa che lo
accompagnano e il dio si intitola il il
tool e ci sono delle persone che pagano
per andare a vedere la riproduzione
olografica di ogni james dio sul centro
del palco che fondamentalmente
sostituisce quel ronnie james dio in
carne ed ossa che è molto nel 2010 in
america stanno in realtà pensando di
fare la stessa cosa con le persone
comuni tra qualche tempo avremo il nonno
sul divano di casa probabilmente
l'ologramma del nonno sul divano di casa
i figli che volevano ereditare le
ricchezze dei genitori si ritroveranno
non poterlo fare perché avranno lollo
gere l'ologramma dei genitori che gli
diranno no non avrete assolutamente la
nostra il nostro consenso
a parte le battute
siamo partiti dallo smartphone che ci
ricorda di fare gli auguri di compleanno
a un amico che è morto
siamo arrivati al rito agli spettri
digitali dei morti siamo arrivati alla
riproduzione delle nostre parole che non
hanno più bisogno di noi
addirittura siamo arrivati agli
ologrammi tutto questo che cosa ci
insegna ci insegna che ogni post che
condividete sui vostri social network
potrebbe una volta che siete morti
prendere il vostro posto diventare il
vostro corpo digitale immortale potrebbe
diventare il vostro alter ego eterno
sta a voi dunque coltivarlo nel modo più
aderente possibile alla vostra identità
affinché siate sostituiti degnamente ed
eternamente dalla vostra memoria social
senza alcun impianto
[Applauso]